i could imagine having a crew like i'll
get food for everyone and just come back
with a bag of these
and you're a hero
[Music]
i'll let you in on a little secret
sometimes the best burgers are the
places you least expect to find them
get ready for an adventure on today's
treasure hunt we're going to hit some
underrated gems of the burger world
first i'm going to meet up with the
legend tony hawk i need a classic
cheeseburger from an iconic mexican food
stand
then i'll link up with my line cook
christian and take him to my
neighborhood spot for a ridiculously
good teriyaki burger
i'm ready you ready let's go
[Music]
uh i flew my drone into a palm tree and
the la city's gonna come help me out
oh man thank god
[Music]
buddy how are you welcome welcome
welcome
so glad you made it out here we had to
switch up the location we're at their
second spot
the first one the block was super hot
parking was an issue the first location
was a bust we're gonna skate here
exactly last time we hung out i made you
three iconic burgers
today we're out in the wild good burgers
don't necessarily have to come from a
burger joint we're at an
unassuming mexican spot that's gonna
serve us one of the best burgers in all
of los angeles so you're saying like not
all great skate spots are actual skate
parks exactly this is that like hidden
gap
that everyone just wants to jump and i'm
glad to share this with you bro
thank you i'm excited let's get it let's
go let's get some burgers
mama and i
run yooka's restaurants it's a family
enterprise
we've been around 45 years since 1976.
the og in los feliz is on hillhurst and
we just opened a new location
four years ago in pasadena mama's the
icon
when i sit downside almost all the
customers coming
hi mama how are you
yooka serves mexican food with the
yucatan flavor
and the american food you know burgers
and stuff frankly we weren't surprised
when our burgers became
a favorite item because we do pay
attention to all the details
[Music]
we pull out a fresh patty from the
refrigerator
we throw it on the grill salt and pepper
over it american cheese if you want
so it melts before it goes on the bun
the mustard ketchup and onion goes on
the top bun
the mayo lettuce and tomato goes on the
bottom bun and always in that order
because then you get the perfect blend
of all the ingredients
we have people that come back 10 15 20
years later
and they say it tastes exactly like they
remember it it makes us feel like
we're doing our job i don't know i was
lucky or god sent me
the special life to the verdict or
something something
you don't know the quality oh the
quality
some of you say burgers yes thank you i
got you one of each
oh beautiful the tacos you'll have to
fight over and that
one fry that's true i got it it's mine
there we go a man of action i love it
thank you so much i cannot wait to try
this
it's legendary i am so happy
yeah happy to be here thank you thanks
for having us thank you i'm talking to
neat guys
all right do it grab some tacos all
right this is what they're known for
this is like the best version of what i
used to eat as a kid i would go to
jack-in-the-box and i would get
one burger one taco exactly burger with
no condiments
taco with meat only you know i was very
simplistic and this is like the absolute
upgraded version of all that i think i'm
gonna start with this taco
like as a palette cleanser yeah same
dude this taco got them a james beard
award i understand why
now brass tacks the burger okay
it's like a gift it's wrapped old school
i like the size i like burgers that
don't feel daunting let's give it a bite
that's so classic i'm having a
ratatouille moment
you know when you have the the taste
you're like oh i'm back it sounds like
childhood
yeah yeah you can tell that griddle
has put some work in you can taste the
years of experience
mayo on the bottom there's lettuce
there's tomato mustard ketchup
onions all separated which is like well
thought out to me
i'm to the point now where like i'm over
the burger trends
this is a everyday for the people
hamburger you know what i mean it's
amazing i can imagine having a crew like
i'll get food for everyone and just come
back with a bag of these
and you're a hero yeah they've cracked
the code
when i come back to places like this and
i have a burger like this it's no wonder
why
los angeles or even southern california
is literally the mecca
of amazing hamburgers all the new stuff
this is like they're
on the shoulders of giants yeah exactly
i suggest
everyone pay homage to
the burger lords at yucas at yucas
in the skate world there's always the
hidden gems
for sure but there's also that risk that
if you're gonna blow up the spot
and it happened to us today so so
do you worry about that as like that
you're doing disservice
i don't know to locals where you're
blowing up these spots
but i recognize them and then it's like
oh thanks dude now the line's
a half hour long every time i go i feel
that but i need great power comes great
responsibility that's what i'm saying
and i accept all of that pressure
because i know customers get a good
burger
and the business makes money and at this
point especially now
we definitely need to be like making
money at restaurants yeah
another one with the man mr tony hawk
thank you so much this was delicious my
compliments to the chef
[Music]
i call this guy up to come with me to go
get one of my favorite burgers it's a
sacred place i live five minutes away
from here
and you show up with a [ __ ] shirt
like this oh this is what i don't wear
to work
you know what i mean now that we're both
double vaxxed
obviously we work together you're my
right hand man you're my burger maestro
it's time to celebrate with some amazing
burgers
it has to be a teriyaki burger cause
we're teriyaki boys
people people don't even understand like
we actually make teriyaki at work
yeah any true southern california native
who loves
this style of food you have to know they
have
a great burger especially if it's
teriyaki on char broiled grill come on
teriyaki check flame broiled
check we're at the right place bro oh
let's fill up them
late oh
get that in there dude you're gonna jump
in there
evans has been open since 99 so for 22
years
we serve japanese fast food teriyaki
chicken and rice the teriyaki bowls
teriyaki avocado cheeseburgers a lot of
people come for the teriyaki bowls but
the smart ones get the burgers too
abc burger is avocado beeman's teriyaki
sauce and cheese
the bun is like an in-n-out bun we do a
burger spread
lettuce tomato pickles onions and then
you could have your choice of american
or swiss cheese
i feel like the char-broiler adds kind
of like the backyard barbecue flavor
and teriyaki is kind of like a japanese
barbecue sauce so
you're cooking it with the meat it
should be thick it should stick to it
our sauce is homemade and it's sweetened
with honey like we'll sell it in
in quart containers or i've sold gallons
from the honey bee
to the bee man kind of all fits together
[Music]
my family has been coming here for the
last 20 years the teriyaki king
can you just like take a sword dub us to
your teriyaki boys
oh yes dude teriyaki boys were official
hey thanks again byron i appreciate you
thank you
thank you for b-mans i love you it's
coming out yeah no doubt
i gotta take my sunglasses off for this
because i've only been to one other b
place shout out to jollibee this is
about to shake your world bro
this is gonna be the bee i don't even
know where it's
start teriyaki chicken teriyaki beef
tsukemono svamasubi portuguese sausage
musubi
put it in my mouth
you got the abc burger which is like
probably the most popular burger on the
menu right
okay okay mine's wrapped in yellow paper
classic
let's take a bite and see how it is
choose a horse
right that's money here's starting the
char grill
i just don't understand why teriyaki
burgers
are slept on oh you got the avocado bump
how does it hold up i mean holding up
physically
it's hard for me emotionally it's there
the sweetness of the teriyaki that's
some thicky thick
thick oh that's some double c thick
right there bro i've always
been a fan of smash burgers yeah the my
art and everything
but something about fat hitting the fire
or like charcoal
or anything like that and then coming
back to your meat that's the key
burger show pro tip if you go into a
teriyaki spot and there's a burger on
the menu
please order the burger because it's
fantastic
fantastic there's us who are like
children of immigrants so this is why we
love the
teriyaki cheeseburger it's all american
but with like
a little bit of flavor and color and
yes neighborhood not even home like i'm
not from japan i'm not from nah man this
is something but it's
like that community taste i'm pretty
sure everyone's probably thinking
this dude works with alvin he does [ __ ]
with him
on the line all the time air out my
dirty laundry bro go ahead tell the
world
tell everyone what it's like to be in
the burger realm
does everyone know that i take all the
photos
that's true he doesn't take any photos
for instagram my social media
is nothing without you bro especially
when it comes to like the burger show
we were able to take it to the next
level because i had someone as
competent and as skilled as yourself
as a team yeah people can't touch us bro
so i'm gonna let you take us out there
you go
burger show baby so like subscribe
click that notification button for me if
not for me
for the burgers
you did great love you man
i felt good all right let's see you at
work don't be
dude don't be late
[Music]
what's up burger world thank you for
watching make sure you hit that like
button
smash that subscribe button ring that
notification bell
if not for me for the burgers
i love you